phil you really didn't have to do this i
sold the house today because of you too
the least i can do is buy you dinner i
saw that house it is gorgeous
we're real happy for them they showed me
a picture of the baby how adorable is
that little guy yes we're real happy for
them
okay you might want to slow down there
when i'm playing a new drinking game
it's called every time i'm depressed i
take a drink
that game exists it's called alcoholism
oh i'm sorry you're right i'm i'm
wallowing and it's not cute
to happier things
i remember the first few drinks
and um after that the night's just bits
and pieces i want to do something i
never do
brag about my kids today they were
resourceful they were responsible they
put 40 down it was worth showing the
house five times and waiting almost a
year
seriously who do you have to blow that's
really hot why don't you let it cool
down and try some of the mexican the
baby is clearly mexican so you know the
swirl is out ugh
it's enough to make you lose track
is this my fourth strength it's my
fourth i just
i think we're gonna need four cabs
two two you made me
i i vaguely remember someone crying
if we ever did surrogacy i would want
you to be the donor you're so smart
you're so handsome stop it it should be
you you're so fun
you're so talented it's not fair i love
you both so much
if you could have a baby that was a mix
of the two of you i would love that baby
so much
oh this is so sweet i meant it that is
so sweet
oh my god you guys we could do this we
could do this we could make a baby that
is half tucker
and half pritchett
are you saying what i think you're
saying
cloning
no
no
i'm saying
i give the egg oh
yeah i give the egg that's the pritchett
side and in cam
you're the father right and then we just
like mix it and put it in a it's like a
circuit lady thing and then bang
we have a baby
oh are you serious you would do that
i would be honored
you guys guys if there's one thing i
have learned today it's the pleasure of
looking at your children and seeing
both both of you in there and i want you
to have a good
experience and something else
guys
i make really good babies yes i have
like magic eggs or something yeah golden
oh gosh oh phil i don't what do you say
about this i think we're all having a
baby
[Applause]
[Music]
sweet potato fries
what have i done i know
oh
hey hey youtube
so where where are the kids oh haley's
driving them over separately oh big girl
now
oh that's great yeah so that was
so fun last night yeah yeah we had a
great night
yes
we should get up jinx
i cannot yeah them
i cannot break their hearts so you're
gonna have camps baby just to keep
things from being weird um what you and
uncle camera having a baby
there was a discussion about the
possibility of your mom donating an egg
so that the guys could have a baby but
we decided it was not a good idea why
because lily's such a mess for a lot of
reasons they have but we can agree that
she's a disastrous human being
i think it's a great idea yeah it's a
really beautiful offer mom i'm impressed
oh my god cam
they told the kids already and they seem
to be totally into it
all right is it just me am i the only
one that thinks this is weird maybe it's
not weird maybe we're pioneers no we're
hardly pioneers you have three different
hair dryers for different types of
weather maybe it's just gonna take some
time to get used to the idea isn't it
enough this family spends a lot of time
together now we have to inbreed okay dad
it's not technically inbreeding it's um
for the record i think what my mom is
doing is very brave i like it i've
always kind of wanted a half-brother
half-cousin really always
it was the last time we talked under a
table dad and gloria's wedding reception
oh yeah
um
i love you do you know that
but i can't do this no no neither can i
really yeah are you serious you can oh
god i'm so relieved i'm sorry i i oh i
am so sorry i let us down this road no
claire don't be don't be it was generous
and thoughtful you know just like you
how could i not want those qualities in
my child no
come here
so this is really happening what if it
is dad yeah what if we love each other
and this is a beautiful thing okay it's
our decision it's not yours oh baby no
baby
[Music]
you